also major breaking news out of this
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania tonight
where the hometown paper of John
fetterman that's right the trust fund
brat the Pittsburgh Post-Gazette has
endorsed officially Dr Oz in what was a
scathing editorial laying out all of
fetterman's struggles from the editorial
quote fetterman's lack of transparency
however in refusing to release his
medical records it's troubling it
suggests an Impulse to conceal and a
mistrust of the people it continues Mr
fetterman despite his hoodies and shorts
and has little experience in holding
real jobs or facing the problems of
working people the editorial closes with
this and a race on which much depends
and little is certain memadize has shown
that he is better equipped to lead and
deliver for Pennsylvania fetterman is
not fit to serve and is pro criminal
record would be a disaster for the great
people of Pennsylvania remember
fetterman voted over and over and over
again to release Island criminals while
on the parole board even convicted
murderers he also said that he wants to
release a third or more prisoners from
Pennsylvania and get this newly
resurfaced audio now shows fetterman
suggesting Republican voters all of you
people in Pennsylvania you're a bunch of
racist take a look
now there are some in the Republican
party that are unreachable
nationalism xenophobia homophobia
just overall I mean that's the southern
strategy right
isn't this the same guy that chased an
innocent African-American that was out
jogging doing nothing wrong down the
street and according to that individual
he took a shotgun pointed it right at
his chest and held him hostage until the
police came that's John fetterman that
did that not a republican also not to
worry because according to Joe Biden
fetterman he's my kind of guy take a
look
thank you
yeah I thought he was really good I
thought he knew what he was doing I
thought he was strong and look fetterman
is Pennsylvania I mean betterment is
everything that he appears to be you
know where he stands he has a great
courage he has no reluctance to say what
he thinks he's my kind of guy
my kind of guy okay Dr Oz is ahead in
this race Now by three points according
to the latest Insider Advantage poll
surging at just the right time fetterman
is now struggling as much as ever
especially especially after the debate
disaster joining us now Pennsylvania
Senate candidate Dr Oz is with us Dr Oz
welcome back to the program uh
apparently I guess Barack Obama's making
the rounds he's going to be headed to
the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania do you
think he'll have any impact on the race
I doubt it and I think what you
witnessed during the debate was that
John fedman can't defend his radical
views I don't think Barack Obama can't
either nor could Joe Biden these extreme
positions are out of touch with
Pennsylvania values and you just did a
couple examples out there but
fundamentally if you're thinking more
about protecting the criminals then the
innocent than the victims which again
what Federman did was to push against
the other members of the parole board to
get murderers out because he's
acknowledged that if he had a magic wand
the one thing he'd want to do is get rid
of life in prison for felony murder this
is just bizarre and especially at a time
when we have a murder rate here in
Philadelphia it's the highest we have
ever had just had our thousandth
carjacking the city is an unmanageable
mess big businesses are leaving but
here's the part that catches me off
guard I wonder if the viewers agree with
me after that debate when there was
issue after issue after issue where
fetterman could not defend taking
radical positions he was able to raise
millions of dollars because all the
Democrats want to do is control the
Senate so help me fight back go to Dr Oz
com we will be able to win this race if
I can tell the truth about John Federman
more than he lies about me but what
you're witnessing is a general belief by
the Democratic party that they don't
have to address the kitchen table issues
of crime of the border which is allowing
fentanyl to make every state of border
state of the economic crises that we're
facing now getting worse by the day gas
prices went up today again and it's
going to be ten dollars a gallon in
Europe but it's going to get back to
five dollars a gallon here in in
Pennsylvania and probably much of the
country if we don't do something about
it
he lied during the debate when he said
he was never for a moratorium on
fracking we have multiple tapes we
played him many times in fact he did say
it numerous times he wants no
restrictions on abortion there's never
been a candidate in the history of the
Senate that I can think of that's
advocated to release more convicted
murderers and violent criminals than him
a guy that brags about his association
with the group black lives matters and
the the street gang the Crips he wants
taxpayers to pay for heroin injection
sites he wants Sanctuary city and state
status all over Pennsylvania and then
you have that little shotgun incident as
he dares to call Republicans racist do
you have any reaction to that
well you just listed a Litany of
problems that he has with law
enforcement that's why the paternal
Order of Police endorsed me unanimously
because they dislike him so much and
they his hometown paper he just
mentioned the Pittsburgh Post-Gazette
which is a a fabulous paper generally
wouldn't endorse the Republican God
bless them they came up to our side
they've had enough as well their big
paper in Pittsburgh the biggest and so
everyone's sort of saying the same thing
let cops do their job make prosecutors
do their job like politicians like
fetterman and me we should both answer
questions from voters he has not done
that yet on the campaign Trail he's not
answering questions from the Press on
the campaign Trail and that debate was
the first and only time he'll take
questions for me they were trying to run
the clock out but they didn't get away
with it and now pennsylvanians pretty
smart folk are looking at the results of
the debate thinking about why he can't
answer simple questions about his
radical positions and realize he doesn't
have good defenses for them they sound
great in 140 character tweet you know
it's great if you're going to be the AOC
of the Senate which is his goal but I'm
not gonna let him get there Pennsylvania
is too important and this and this is
important we do not have a Republican
senator north of North Carolina on the
Atlantic coast until you get to Maine if
I don't hold this seat and there's been
a Republican senator in Pennsylvania
most of my life I'm going to keep one
here as well and this is a state that
because it's so important to the country
a top five State we want a republican
presence here to make sure it's well
represented along with other states that
have our issues big cities like
Philadelphia that have some issues
around poverty a lot of energy in the
state we've got to make sure these
issues are addressed Republicans can do
it well
well I'd like to remind people when
Barack Obama is there uh campaigning for
Mr fetterman uh that it was Barack Obama
who referred to the people of
Pennsylvania as bitter Americans that
cling to their God Guns their Bibles and
religion I hope people didn't forget
that part and maybe somebody in the
media might have enough guts to ask
Obama if he still believes that about
the people of Pennsylvania Dr Oz thanks
for being with us we'll follow this race
closely the next eight days hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else